let's talk about this uh story we got
here the uh Georgia judge sets October
23rd trial date for Trump co-defendant
Kenneth chaseborough
I think that's something y'all should
consider let me first give you a little
context a Georgia judge on Thursday
signed off on a quick turnaround to the
start of the trial for Kenneth
chasborough one of the 18 defendants
charged alongside former president
Donald Trump in connection with the
alleged efforts to overturn the 2020
election the ruling scheduling October
23 start date came to stuff for Trump's
newly appointed attorney said he would
move to several the former president's
case from chaseborough or any other
defendant who sought an expedited
timeline
what's what are the chances and I
understand
some people might say it's not legally
possible
I don't care
what are the chances Kenneth Chase Perot
convicted
convicted November
and then they say
Donald Trump was charged for the exact
same things
and if this guy was convicted Trump
should not be on the ballot either
because he's a co-conspirator we we
moved to 14th Amendment his name off the
ballot he accept he's charged not
convicted doesn't matter Trump shouldn't
be charged in the first place his lawyer
should be charged in the first place my
point is this
several months ago if I were to tell you
they're going to indict Jenna Ellis for
being Trump's lawyer people would be
like well they can't legal counsel is a
protected as president of the
Constitution and then they did so
they'll have their PR excuse but I don't
know Donald Trump was The Mastermind but
can they charge someone's lawyer can
Jenna Ellis is accused of accounts one
and two literally being part of a
criminal experience a conspiracy and
solicitation of a violation of oath of
office literally just because she was
Trump's lawyer other people in the
charges were reaching out to people and
asking them to do things and Jenna
Ellis's counsel counts one and two
we said this months ago oh they can't
indict Trump performance never happened
but then they did that or a year ago
sure we oh they're not going to go after
his lawyers they are I said next up is
Media personalities now we're hearing
James O'Keefe is under investigation
criminal investigation in New York it's
going to keep happening that's why I'm
saying like
yeah maybe maybe the legal theory is
Trump's not been convicted but the
argument they will make is Trump was The
Mastermind who ordered Chase bro to do
these things for which he's been
convicted that proves it as far as
anyone needs to understand that Trump is
an Insurrection I don't know that it
matters because Eugene B deps
Eugene B Debs was a socialist who ran
for president multiple times from prison
there's precedent yes but they'll remove
his name from the ballot under the 14th
Amendment Trump can run all he wants and
they'll say yeah that's fine but your
name won't be on the ballot because the
14th Amendment says you're an
insurrectionist you can be a socialist
in prison still run that we know but
they're they've already done this to
um what's the guy's name in uh uh New
Mexico you know what I'm talking about
New Mexico politician got removed from
uh the election because they called him
an insurrectionist they tried using it
on Marjory Taylor green and Madison
cawthorne you want to look you look at
it but he's not convicted what I'm
saying is that
if he's not convicted technically until
he's convicted how do you remove a Snape
in the ballot he's still charged you
can't say moving someone's name from the
bound to the 14th Amendment would be
novel
exactly and so the issue is this what's
his name it's um
coup Griffin Griffin Griffin yeah koi
Griffin that's right he they said he was
an insurrectionist so he's ineligible
now
Donald Trump
is The Mastermind of the conspiracy who
gave the instructions right
allegedly allegedly and if this guy is
convicted
what does he say in court about what
Trump told him to do
and then they can say this is not about
a criminal conviction of Donald Trump
this is about a statement of facts sworn
under oath that Donald Trump instructed
an individual to assist him in
Insurrection thus disqualified uh as an
elected uh to run for office his name
should be removed from the ballot I'm
not saying that they might not try that
but that's one of those where you got to
get really black pilled I hope at some
point the Supreme Court's saying well
he's not convicted yet dummies I mean
let's hope that maybe the cover of the
Constitution can remember not but I'm
not talking about the criminal case I'm
saying in this criminal trial of Kenneth
chaseborough he will be asked what did
Donald Trump tell you
thus they will launch a civil suit
against Trump outside of any
requirements of criminal conviction to
say
witness testimony in a criminal case
Trump instructed these people to engage
in Insurrection adding on top January 6
statements people strumming the capital
all of that they'll play Clips out of
context this will add to we're not
trying to criminally charge him that's a
totally different case we're saying he
waged Insurrection therefore he's
ineligible yeah I don't know that's
where I say please get Robert Burns in
here and ask him that because but it's
not a legal question it's a political
election law well it's election law too
I mean
considering they've indicted Trump's
lawyers I don't think it's a little
ballot access is absolutely election law
right but
they could do anything they want because
the law is not
is is not written by the Lord law is
written by men and is ignored all the
time yeah the fact that they've arrested
Trump's lawyers
sets the standard they can do anything
they want they will make up whatever
they want so my question is just you
know maybe you're right maybe it's just
this is the line where they say well
we've we've violated the Constitution
we've we've created new novel ways of of
Prosecuting people but this one time we
stopped well I'm kind of hoping that
this fails I mean it is dark obviously
they're arresting Council and I find it
completely disturbing and I hope there's
a backlash and that's why I'm pissed off
about a lazy ass Congress it's not
pulling her up there because the feds
need to be coming down and they need to
be saying what the hell is going on the
state managed to get it together they
must get two houses in Georgia itself
that is landing an investigation of her
we've got this problem why isn't Jack
Smith under investigation why are we
being so damn lazy on one side well
maybe because we really kind of like the
idea that Trump's getting put away maybe
we kind of want another candidate to
come up there maybe we like you know
exactly sure so they're they're sitting
there going like no wait don't Democrats
and we're going yeah you tell them and
then they go to the same parties and
hook up with same escorts and drink the
same wine
they hate the people
yes
yep plain simple I mean even if they
don't hate the people they're at the
very least not interested in serving the
people and interested in maintaining
their own power and staying in
Washington DC and you know eating the
good food and living in the nice places
and going to the nice places and stuff
so you know and they're indifferent to
the you know to the what is actually
legal you know what the law says these
are the people that when you go to the
halls of Congress and knock on the door
and you walk in they're all smiling and
saying how can we help you and you're
like I just wanted to you know leave a
letter for the congressman the back
thank you so much and then when they
walk out they'll go oh and they start
wiping themselves off and the
congressman pops out and goes oh it was
in here they don't like you these these
people don't like you there's like 12
members of Congress maybe 20 that like
you overwhelmingly they don't they're
all you are is a number they're having
meetings with their Consultants saying
look I just want to get more votes what
do I need and they're like people like
red have you considered wearing red
you'll get more votes that way they
don't go to someone and say what you can
situent you're a farmer what should I
wear a red tie or a blue tie so I I
don't think it matters I'm wondering why
the prices are going up for my cost for
my fuel it's like okay well I'm gonna
wear the red tie that's what they are
they're not actually they're not
actually I this is why I think we were
talking to
um return to Freedom caucus I can't
remember which one
he said that they had the votes to
overturn Obamacare and Republican
leadership came to them and said but
don't do it because we're going to use
this to campaign
they do not care about you
that's it's just it's got to stop man
and I don't know that Maga is it but
certainly whatever it is populism is
bringing is politicians who are actually
talking with constituents and maybe this
is it maybe this maybe it's social media
for all of its uh for all of its
negatives has some positives in that as
we form our own communities where we
care about issues the representatives
that we elect share share those values
much the same way because they're part
of the same spheres
no you had to sponsor right you were
just talking about what Public Square
yeah well that's power I mean what's
happening with Bud Light is a real thing
yeah and I really do believe Andrew
Breitbart was correct when he said
politics is Downstream of culture yep
and if the culture divide you've got a
show about culture
that's going to push the politics
because they can't afford to keep going
against it if the culture turns they
have to go with it ultimately right so
we agree you've got to change the
culture I completely agree
that's everything that's why you know
most of the stuff most of the stuff we
do here we'll talk politics but most of
our investments are not political I see
no point I've donated to political
candidates a bunch of times but I don't
see a real point in doing that I'll put
it this way Tucker Carlson where is he
most effective doing a show or being
president what do you think sure
absolutely the cultural force of him
coming out and talking to people and
inspiring people way more important than
signing an executive order Oliver
Anthony you're a band absolutely he's
he's most effective when uh he has a
show and Trump is the president because
then Trump just listens oh yeah well
there's that too that's a cultural
pipeline yeah exactly Trump's on Air
Force One just watching Tucker Carlson
that's what he did he's had someone
taking notes for him while he shows down
yeah I wish we get some like behind the
scenes footage of them hanging out in
Maine while they like film that
interview no they were in Bedminster oh
they were I'm pretty sure Tucker went to
New Jersey
yeah I don't think Trump's gonna travel
to
you know I just know that's where his
studio is or that's where he's here's
another thing to consider maybe the real
reason or a reason Trump didn't go to
the debates there's no way he can go to
Milwaukee debate and then fly to Atlanta
the next day turn himself in I heard it
was pre-recorded though no no I'm saying
if he flew to Milwaukee for a live
debate oh well yeah and then he left at
midnight and flew back and then he has
to fly back the next day
that's brutal but he was saying that he
wasn't gonna he wasn't really interested
in doing the debates for way before
Georgia right he could have turned
himself in before or whatever yeah well
and like he has been saying I don't see
the point of this I'm clearly in the
lead all of you guys are just going to
you know try and attack me like I it
doesn't it only benefited the RNC if
Trump won because more people will tune
in to watch and fox yeah you saw that
they they wouldn't let Don Jr in and
Kimberly Guilfoyle which is Chris and
Larry Elder which by the way I'm super
annoyed about that I'm really annoyed
because you had Tim Scott seems like a
great guy but come on if you could have
Tim Scott or Larry Elder in a debate now
hold on there a minute I would not mind
Tim's Tim Scott's actually pulling
really well I think he I think he's
doing better than a lot uh Chris
Christie thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time